it's a new movie in the marvel cinematic
universe so you know it's full of
references to the comics and movies that
have come before and maybe the stories
to come too these are the easter eggs
you missed in chiang chi and the legend
of the ten rings
writer director destin daniel cretan has
gone on record saying chang-chi is set
after the so-called blip when all of the
victims of thanos's snap have returned
after five long years away the timeline
is established in the movie by dialogue
and the set dressing take a close look
at the scene early in chiang chi when
sean visits katie and her family as he
pulls open the exterior door to her
building you can see a flyer reading
post-blip anxiety you're not alone
this might be the kind of sign that
advertised the rogers support group that
he hosted after the snap as seen in
avengers end game of course that scene
took place before everyone's return and
steve ultimately was giving advice that
he may have ended up regretting
you gotta move on
yeah or maybe you have to go back in
time and kick as many asses as it takes
to sort this mess out the group
advertised in chiang chi seems to be not
only for those with loved ones who
vanished but also the people who
returned after years away at the time
when xiangchi is set anxiety is a common
affliction now that androids aliens and
wizards are commonplace how can a normal
person feel like anything other than an
ant hoping to not get squashed
man
[Music]
that's what they called you
in the mid-credits scene shanghai and
katie have a conversation with a virtual
captain marvel and bruce banner along
with dr strange wingman wong the brain
trust is extremely interested in the ten
rings the tale of how xiangxi acquired
them and their true nature they debate
the ring's power and origin with carol
danvers calling them unlike any alien
tech she's ever seen eventually they
seem to conclude that the rings are some
sort of beacon sending a message for
purposes unknown then banner signs off
by saying guys stay safe welcome to the
circus it's a fun cameo scene that seems
to set up our heroes for future avengers
collaborations but sharp eyed viewers
might also notice that banner's right
arm isn't a sling any guesses why as you
recall in avengers endgame it was
determined that only the hulk was strong
enough to wear the stark gauntlet and
snap everyone back into existence but in
doing so he was exposing himself to
massive gamma radiation and sure enough
he fried his arm in a 2019 interview
with comicbook.com endgame director joe
russo said the damage is permanent
according to him he's lost an arm that's
not coming back he's damaged himself
it's permanent damage the same way there
was permanent damage with thanos it's
irreversible so will bruce banner spend
the rest of his mcu games with his arm
in a sling in a world where thor can pop
in a new eye and roadie can become
paralyzed from a fractured spinal column
but walk again with help from stark
bionic supports no injury seems truly
permanent we'll see how long ruffalo has
to keep wearing the sling but in this
his first hulk scene since endgame is
clear that he's still in a bad way
sharp eyed fans were delighted when
earlier this summer they seem to uncover
a quick shot of abomination in the
xiangxi trailer sure enough when our
newly revealed hero makes his way back
to china in an attempt to locate his
sister charling he looks for her at the
golden daggers club and discovers that
not only does she run the place but
currently appearing on the main stage is
a smackdown between the incredible hulk
villain and wong for starters there are
several things worth discussing about
emil blonsky's monstrous appearance
first he seems to be evolving or at the
very least the cgi is getting better
after all it has been 13 years since we
last saw the guy he now has ear fins
that look fully engaged and he boasts
more prominent dorsal spine needles both
signatures that make abomination stand
out on the comic book page the second
interesting thing worth noting is that
the character looks even less like tim
roth than he did before which is saying
something because he has never really
looked much like him to begin with over
the last decade marvel fans have watched
us hulk has increasingly resembled the
actor who played him with story lines
that sought to humanize the monster
within bruce banner but while the
incredible hulk gave us an abomination
whose face at least somewhat resembled a
human's reactions the abomination
character design now seems to be moving
in the opposite direction of hulk
leaving all humanity behind you have to
explain that statement
no i don't perhaps the most notable
thing about this abomination however
might be his shift in tone as you may
recall after abomination nearly defeated
hulk in harlem general thunderbolt ross
had the creature locked up in a
high-tech cell in alaska phil coulson
said in a 2014 episode of agents of
shield that he was still in that cryo
cell but in the 2011 one-shot short film
the consultant an angry cousin says the
world security council once abomination
released and assigned to the avengers
initiative carlson says that the council
considers blonsky to be a war hero they
want him exonerated released and added
to the avengers roster in a conclusion
played for laughs shield reveals in the
short film that they purposefully sent
tony stark to screw up the negotiations
leading to the incredible hulk post
credits cameo where he clashed with a
hard-drinking ross and as a result
ablonski went back into custody
the abomination will remain in his cage
for now
but clearly blonsky is not only on the
loose post blip but he seems to be
chummy with wonk who shang chi reveals
to be a major player in the recruitment
of new avengers could it be that
whatever remnants remain of the world
security council finally got their way
and abomination will soon be fighting on
the same side as hulk abomination is
gearing up to appear more frequently in
the marvel sandbox including in the
upcoming she-hulk disney plus series
how do you feel
[Music]
pissed off i'm ready for round three
the first real indication to sean that
his reality is about to get very very
expanded is when he and katie are
attacked on a san francisco bus by
several highly trained men one of them
wielding a machete in place of his right
forearm as well red comic fans will be
eager to point out his name is razer
fist and you wouldn't want to try and
shake his hand in the comics razor fist
was introduced in 1975 in master of kung
fu number 29 as a henchman of the evil
colton velcro this villain had a razor
sharp blade on each arm not that it
helped him much as he died three issues
later shut down by velcro's guards of
course no comics mantle however obscure
is ever laid down for good velcro
attempted to create more razor fists in
1981 when brothers william and douglas
carter in a car accident he gave them
sword arms too douglas died and william
became the new razorfest in more recent
years that razor fist has appeared in
various comics usually seen as
supporting muscle for super villains
much like we find him in chongqi
in the background of almost every scene
containing wenwu you may have noticed a
silent man dressed in black wearing
white makeup punctuated by streaks of
red and black that guy's name is death
dealer and for good reason in the comics
the character's real name is lee
chinglin and like other characters in
chiang chi's orbit he has a history with
mi6 the baddie was actually a double
agent working on this life of fu manchu
when he and xiang chi had an epic battle
that nearly killed him and he then took
on the death dealer persona in chiang
chi in the legend of the ten rings this
death dealer has clearly been with wenwu
for multiple decades and seems to have
largely led the training that taught
sean every possible way to kill a man
the mysterious nature of the live-action
character coupled with the lack of
dialogue has given rise to some
interesting theories about death dealer
whose story will certainly be explored
in future movies in the mcu
okay technically this easter egg isn't
in chiang chi in the legend of the ten
rings but you'll likely glimpse it in
one of the trailers that plays before
the film in the multiverse expanding
first trailer for spider-man no way home
dr stephen strange makes a really really
bad decision to cast a spell that will
make the entire world forget that peter
parker is spider-man under normal
circumstances an mcu fan would say no
way wong would never let such an
irresponsible thing happen he's the
voice of reason great point but when the
cat's away the mice will play so while
we see wong in the trailer instructing
strange not to mess with the spell we
also see him in a winter parker holding
two suitcases and traveling somewhere
that looks like it has old regal
structures adorned by columns and domes
which is when strange casters spell on
peter's behalf and all hell breaks loose
those who have seen chiang chi know that
wang pops up multiple times in china as
well as san francisco so could either of
those be where he's teleporting to in
the trailer do the events of that scene
run concurrent to shanghai we'll find
out soon enough when spidey's latest
adventure slings itself into theaters
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
xiangxi and the legends of the 10 rings
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]